[Music]
new tonight as las vegas continues to
bounce back we're seeing rising rent
prices and a hot housing market
and for some that means they're fighting
just to stay in their homes or even to
find new ones
sasha lava spoke with one valley couple
who's stepping up to help others
and advocate for more affordable options
sasha
the danner family is really in a rough
spot aren't they
yes denise just one of many that is
still struggling to find housing
here in las vegas the danner's hope that
their efforts to speak out the courage
to speak out here
will assist others in the same sort of
situation
it's a ripple effect that i'm afraid
will be a giant tsunami in the desert
jim and julie dinner
are the couple that answers the call are
you ready for easter
for the past year they've turned their
garage into a pantry
to feed hundreds of struggling families
but a few weeks ago
they had to put their mission on pause
it's heartbreaking i look at the page
people message me every day like
do you have any food for us their
landlord is selling the property they
rent
so they're scrambling to find a place to
live but i think we're going to see a
little bit of a wave before we start to
see a downtrend
lending expert andrew levitz says a hot
housing market and a lack of local rent
control laws
have made the process impossible for so
many
so when you're getting through the
process of trying to rent a home and
it's nearly the same of purchasing a
property it's causing a lot of issues
for people
leavitt says it's important to know your
weaknesses
and be upfront with any application we
need something to stop this
you know price gouging rent situation
for these people
in our community but the banners are
calling for real change
across our state and an affordable
option
for those who are out of answers your
community is suffering
suffering we are suffering and we need
help
now if you are renting a home that is
being sold by the property owner
law says nevada law here says that the
new owner has to honor that lease to its
end now if you need help
with housing assistance or you know
anyone that could help the danners we
have information on our website
8newsnow.com reporting live tonight
sasha loftis
8 news now